it's really changing the perception of
how we see things and if we can change
the perception of it
we reduce the stress reaction the
physical part of that like right away
experiencing a stress response isn't
harmful per se what makes it harmful is
when our stress response is triggered
and then remains chronically elevated
over time the difference between
excitement and anxiety is more
or less just the the framing it's just
the story you're telling yourself wanna
be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn about
the stress response system and how you
can manage your stress levels
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one deactivate the stress with john
assaraf inner size number one is called
take six calm the circuits there it is
so there are two major circuits in the
human brain the parasympathetic nervous
system or circuit and the sympathetic
nervous system so when we have um a
disempowering experience a fear a stress
anxiety
uncertainty self-doubt
the sympathetic nervous system has
kicked in
and basically
the neurochemicals of cortisol
epinephrine norepinephrine adrenaline
kick in and we just don't like that
feeling in a lot of cases
it also shuts down motivational centers
in our brain it shuts down our thinking
and imagination center in our brain and
so we're in a heightened state of
disempowerment and procrastination and
fear and the fight-or-flight thing you
were talking about earlier
fight-or-flight kicks in so one of the
first things to do is whenever you feel
you know anxious angry stressed
uncertain you take six deep breaths in
through your nose
and then out through your mouth but blow
out like you're blowing out through a
straw so in through your nose one two
three four and then pucker your lips a
little
and focus on the airflow coming out of
your mouth for four seconds five seconds
six seconds
when you do that just six times
takes
less than one minute to a max of 90
seconds you actually deactivate
the sympathetic
circuitry
which causes us to have you know
elevated heartbeat
elevated blood pressure and it activates
the parasympathetic
so in the stress so you're frankenstein
to your einstein you got it so when
frankenstein activates right you're in a
stress mode
and to deactivate the stress mode you do
take six calm the circuits and that puts
you in the calm and respond mode so it's
stress and react calm and respond rule
number two change your perception with
robert zambroski you have a practice
you're going through chemo these are not
stress-free things so how how did you
and i like the notion of pulling weeds
how did you tend that garden
i didn't want to get ill again
and i didn't want to have something
influence my biology again
to maybe set the stage for
recurrence remission i hate those words
as well but it just sets the negative
mindset up for people and i'm a driver
you know my mental mindset as i said
when i woke up
i'm rebuilding
when i got clear and the tubes are out
and i'm back at the gym
i'm going to take this to a new level so
it's just i wanted to push myself to a
different level each phase i wanted to
do something different
and so as i said the stress is a big
thing and there's no stress people are
like oh you're worried about this that
and money if i'm like nope
the house can burn down who cares stress
is a perception unless it's a physical
thing you break your ankle sunburn you
know those are physical stressors but
there's two things that people need to
realize
and that i realize
one stress is a perception
the stress reaction tom is something
totally different like we need to
separate the two if you can change your
perception of the thing that's stressing
you out that's finances you get a new
car we take a ride somebody hits it
you're like oh my god my new car i'm
like dude it's metal let's just go get
it fixed you'll have a new one next week
you know so it's really changing the
perception of how we see things and if
we can change the perception of it
we reduce the stress reaction the
physical part of that like right away
do you meditate
i do well i don't i don't know if i call
it meditation but i i i i sit quietly
and i tap into the universe and maybe
that's what do you mean by that i
download i'm downloading at the gym i'm
just i'm just i connect i connect with
universal laws and energy yeah so for me
i just when i put my feet on the ground
i thank
the universe
god whatever it may be i thank
th that energy source for for me being
alive
i thank it for my intelligence i thank
it for my want to help other people
and so when i plant my feet on the
ground it's the first thing that i do
because it sets the stage from my
mindset every day
every day in the hotel room it doesn't
matter every day because then it just
helps me set my mindset like you want to
have some way to set your mindset so you
don't wake up and just go oh my god i
got all these things happening and then
you're out of your mind your perceptions
are off you start to release stress
hormones you're eating like crap you're
destroying your immune system and here
you go you start to brew disease
so for me it's it's perception
and if i can change my perception daily
i tom i've been through life-threatening
disease i had the green ripper tapping
with me with a sickle
so stressors for me just become whatever
like whatever
what why would i freak out about
something one that perhaps i can't
control and if i can change my
perception what if i can what if i can
change the stressful situation to
something positive rule number three
experience stress with ethan cross
can chatter
make us ill well i think the answer that
question is yes and it um
it's interesting because i think many
people
can easily relate to having the
experience of stress
but
for throughout time stress has been this
it's kind of abstract thing that happens
in your head and things that happen in
your head have lack the same kind of
concreteness we can't feel it the same
way
that we can uh you know we can feel a
wound swell in our body or see like our
arteries get filled with with plaque and
um
other things that you know create lead
to heart attacks and things like of that
sort so so i think actually the brain
imaging that has evolved over the past
20 years has helped a lot with that in
the in terms of helping people see how
stress can manifest in the brain and how
that can in turn have downstream
implications for health but the way this
works the the snapshot that exists so
how does stress actually make us
physically ill
one of the leading theories is the idea
that
as human beings we are designed to
experience stress right experiencing
stress is a really useful adaptive
response to a threat in our environment
it's a good system to have
i wouldn't want my worst enemy to not be
able to experience stress because they
wouldn't survive well in the world
experiencing a stress response isn't
harmful per se what makes it harmful is
when our stress response is triggered
and then remains chronically elevated
over time
that exerts a wear and tear on the body
that we are not
designed for
and what helps keep our stress responses
active over time
it's me getting an email last night that
i wasn't so happy about
and replaying that email in my head
hearing the words spoken over and over
and over again and replaying that email
today and tomorrow thinking how i'm
going to respond this may or may not be
a hypothetical event by the way
but but it is our our minds are capable
of of of maintaining our stress
responses and when you get people who
are ruminating or worrying for long
stretches of time
that's what the mind is doing
it's keeping us in that stress state
and that has been shown to predict a
host of physical maladies that range
from cardiovascular disease
to problems of inflammation to various
forms of of cancer and so
the link to our physical health is there
it's strong and i think it's one of the
three big reasons to really be concerned
about chatter rule number four practice
elevated emotions with dr joe dispenza
so imagine then you have an inner army
of plasma cells of white blood cells
that release immunoglobulins
antibodies that are strong defenses
against internal invaders on a
microscopic level that memorize those
invaders pass the information to the
legion of white blood cells so that your
immune system can tolerate and defend
you
in any foreign agent in your inner world
now our research has shown
along with several other people that
when people can trade those survival
emotions those stress hormones like fear
and anxiety and pain and suffering and
anger and frustration and judgment and
competition
for more elevated emotions more
heart-centered emotions it is those
heart-centered emotions that we are able
to open our heart and feel uh kindness
and compassion and to have a love for
life and to feel gratitude and
appreciation really work with our body
to elevate our emotional state
it makes sense then that if we do this
properly we are going to convert
from the gas pedal of the sympathetic
nervous system
to teach our body to break that pattern
of constantly being in survival
and we start to feel elevated emotions
we feel less separate from everyone and
everything and we start to feel more
connected to everyone and everything and
when we do this properly and we start to
open our hearts
our research shows that we begin to
strengthen our immune system
in fact our research shows that for 10
minutes a day three times a day
if you practiced feeling those elevated
emotions
you would begin to release an
immunoglobulin called immunoglobulin a
which is your body's primary defense
against bacteria and viruses it is the
body's natural flu shot
that creates an immunity to the
environment both macroscopically and
microscopically
so then 10 minutes a day three times a
day
changing your mood and breaking the
stress response and teaching your body
that it feels safe enough to be in the
present moment
that it can create that it's moving out
of survival
but doing this properly the body's so
objective that it does not know the
difference between the experience and
the environment that's creating the
emotion of love and gratitude and you
doing it by volition your body begins to
move more into the present moment and
here comes the parasympathetic nervous
system
and now its job is to restore
to rebalance to repair to increase
metabolic functions to release
1300 different chemicals that can begin
to restore and repair your body the body
now is moving out of emergency
and there are resources to heal
and so
feeling those heart-centered emotions
and changing from fear say to love
is going to begin to cause those white
blood cells those plasma cells
to release the proper proteins
epigenetically they're going to cause
your body to have a strength against any
virus bacteria a fungus or mold or even
cancer cell and we've proven
that our our students by reversing
cancer have done this very exact thing
our work is about something else it's
about changing our inner state by
thought alone
and so
when we do this properly and we trade
those survival emotions for elevated
emotions
and we're able to practice that every
day
it makes sense to us then that people
are going to start to heal and they are
going to produce a legion
of strong white blood cells that can
memorize and attack any foreign agents
and there's been other research
that shows that as fear levels go up
it suppresses uh our immune system
dramatically and when we elevate our
emotions
uh we see then that uh that we reverse
that process
also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief the sign
says it can take up to
254 days of consecutive action for the
habit to stick that's what i want for
you so i've designed a custom free
program we're going to send you an
unlisted video for the next 254 days to
shift your confidence and belief forward
the link to join is in the description
below you were up and dressed and ready
to go before your parents were up you
know why because you knew something
unexpected was going to happen that's
how we should live our lives waking up
with the understanding to expect the
unexpected if you didn't give a [ __ ]
what anybody else thought
what's the thing you would love to be
doing with your life people want to know
how to stop the laziness and they want
to know how to stop the procrastination
rule number five interrupt the negative
patterns with mel robbins you have this
behavior pattern where you snap you have
this behavior pattern where you yell and
you get upset and you make people wrong
and you don't mean to
if you are somebody who's ever said to
yourself i wish i could stop yelling or
i wish i i i i could just snap i could
stop snapping
this video is absolutely
okay and the reason why is i explained
this research that was so
mind-blowing for me
it's called ghosts in the nursery
a lot of the patterns that you have
that you don't have control over
are patterns from your childhood
and they are
there because when you were a kid
you experienced people in your life that
were tense
did you ever have a parent that was a
yeller
did you ever have a teacher that was a
yeller or a coach that was a yeller and
secretly in your little kid body
whenever your mom or dad would yell or
your coach would yell or your teacher
would yell or your grandmother or
grandfather would yell you would feel
tense right
you would feel nervous you would feel on
edge of course that's how we all feel
right well here's the reason why
you might have an issue like i used to
have an issue where i would yell at my
kids and then i'd feel terrible about it
i'd snap at my husband and then i'd feel
terrible about it psychologists and then
i would say to myself i'm not doing that
again i'm not doing that again but i
wouldn't have the ability to end it
psychologists call this ghost in the
nursery
it means that any situation where you
start to feel
tense or you start to feel stressed out
guess what happens your body remembers
what it was like when you were little to
feel tense and stressed out and what
were the adults doing around you when
you felt that way
they were snapping
they were yelling and now here you are
repeating the pattern
and you don't know why and you feel
guilty
and i'm explaining this to you because
it wasn't until i thought holy cow like
i know i don't want to snap at my
husband i know i don't want to take my
anger from work out on my family
why can't i stop this
that's the reason why it's because it's
a pattern that you remember from being a
kid that the adults around you were
snapping or yelling or being mean
any time and when they were you felt
tense and stressed out so now that
you're an adult when you're tense and
stressed out you repeat the behavior
that you witnessed crazy right so how do
you stop it well the first step to
stopping anything is to actually
understand what you're dealing with
now that you know you're dealing with a
pattern now all you need to do is
basically say okay i'm going to put a
practice in place that's going to
interrupt this pattern what's the
practice well a really good one is
[Music]
before you walk in the house at the end
of the day if you're stressed out take
five
take five deep breaths
like reset your mood reset your energy
before you walk in the house and you'll
be surprised by how much nicer you are
to the people around you
another thing that um that uh
you can do and this one's not so fun
is you can train your
partner your kids your roommates your
family that if you're trying to get a
hold of how you bring stress home you
can train them to say to you hey
don't take your work stress out on me
when somebody that you care about says
that to you it's a humbling experience
and the person that says it the most in
my life is my son oakley your uh the
youngsters seem to love to cross-check
the adults so be careful with taking
that advice rule number six embrace
stress with andrew huberman there is
something called adrenal insufficiency
syndrome which is a real medical
phenomenon where the adrenals are
incapable of making these cortisol and
adrenal hormones but
the the truth is that you have enough
adrenaline and cortisol in your body to
last two lifetimes and 25 famines i mean
we were built with a lot of robustness
right this explains you know that you
know the david goggins of the world they
they you know we we all do have that
greater capacity that people talk about
the stress is very misunderstood because
people think of stress as this ancient
carryover that's very unfortunate it
kind of gets lumped with depression like
oh this is just a
flaw in our design or something but
actually stress is wonderful it actually
activates our immune system so
anytime you liberate adrenaline into
your bloodstream you also protect
yourself against infection of bacteria
and viruses because if you think about
if we had to gather food and we didn't
have it and we had to then pack up and
you know migrate long distances you
can't afford to get sick and this is why
people who work work work work and then
rest they usually get sick when they
finally stop and rest yeah it's like the
post finals phenomenon in university or
after the season for a game or the
caretakers thing where you're taking
care of somebody who's ill and you're
just
work work work or taking care of young
children and then you finally stop to
rest you go on vacation and you get
slammed with with what is that because
you're being cut in your comfort zone
now are you because stress turned off
and adrenaline
so that these the stress response
recruits the immune
organs of the body to release killer t
cells in fact wim hof breathing i know
you're familiar with whim
of doing 20 or 30 deep inhales and
exhales
and also combined with some breath hold
type work exhale hold inhale hold is
known to stimulate adrenaline release
and the one of the better papers that's
out there scientific peer-reviewed
papers is a study published in the
proceedings in national academy of
sciences where they brought in two
groups
one group
did wim hof breathing
the other group did just uh mindful
meditation both groups were injected
with e coli
right crazy right
it's crazy the meditators got fever
diarrhea and um and vomiting and the
people who did wim wimhoff
either didn't get it or got it to a much
lesser extent sluggish but that's right
they didn't right this is not an
experiment to do at home isn't this
crazy but it makes perfect sense because
it inc that breathing simulates a stress
response it stimulates cortisol and
adrenaline which signals protects the
body right which signals to the thymus
the spleen and the other you know the
the nodes of the immune system to
liberate killer cells and so when that
bacteria comes in the system is ready
for it
your body is defending against viruses
that's right disease that's right
essentially
when you create a routine of healthy
stress that's right and we can talk
about we definitely want to
you don't want stress on all the time
sleep is really important etc but that
stress response combats
infection because it recruits immune
cells rule number seven detach and take
control with jocko willing there's been
thousands
and hundreds of thousands and millions
of warriors
that have been
in
very
stressful situations and faced evil and
faced death
much worse
than the situation
i'm in or urine that we might consider
stressful and i even did this when i was
overseas when i was on deployment when i
was a combat leader
i was feeling stress
and you know what we took casualties and
it was awful and it was heartbreaking
and
but there
were other
soldiers and warriors throughout time
that have been in much worse situations
gettysburg or vicksburg or the battle
the bulge
and in all those
horrible situations
they prove really that humans can
withstand almost
almost unimaginable stress
which meant to me
that i could too
and
you can
and the first step for me is doing that
taking that
look to gain some perspective
and then in order to gain perspective
you got to do something that we already
talked about you've got to detach you've
got to detach from the problems or the
stress that you're experiencing
so that you can get that perspective of
them
now
there's a couple different types of
stress now if it's something that you
can control that's causing you stress
well
why aren't you getting control of it now
there's also stress that's caused by
things that you cannot control
and if you remember
talking earlier
about artillery
and how horrible that was and what made
it so horrible was that there's no
control over
so if you can't control something
and you can't get control of it
you have to
at least
embrace what you can and i'm not saying
you're going to embrace artillery
shelling but i'll tell you what when it
comes to things like artillery or
for us in ramadi was ieds
and we could do everything we could do
to mitigate that risk
but eventually there's only so much you
can do and you cannot completely
eliminate it
but you can't control it so why are you
going to worry about it why are you
going to stress about it
if there's something that's completely
beyond your control
you cannot you've got to detach from it
and not let yourself get stressed about
it
and on top of that
if it's something that you can't control
how can you look at it in a different
light how can you see it in a way that
you could actually take advantage of it
how can you take
that stress and make it into some kind
of ally you know the
the chaos of combat
is something that i couldn't control but
i had to embrace it so i could try and
figure out how to take advantage of it
so when it comes to stress
don't fight it
turn it on itself and use it
use it use it to make yourself sharper
and more alert
and use it to make yourself think more
and learn more and get better
and use that stress
as a catalyst
to make yourself better rule number
eight watch your diet with drew ramsey
if you think about
your brain as the lens through which
you're filtering all this data
right is is the line on the screen a
line on the screen or is it actually in
the room with you about to eat you your
your brain is very good at sorting that
out um and
and if we think about the quality of
that lens really being influenced by a
few things or a few processes one you
mentioned like the microbiome that's
really talking about inflammation how
does this word of inflammation affect
the brain if we think about it in terms
of my favorite concept these days
neuroplasticity right brain growth and
brain change over time
uh
definitely food influences that there
are a bunch of
specific molecular mechanisms where we
can see that now and so that's how i
think about the way that we try and sort
that out is thinking have there been
changes in your diet sometimes i need to
see people like oh my gosh my anxiety is
so much worse it's because i'm just
i freaked out i'm just eating comfort
foods i've eaten pasta for three days i
haven't had a vegetable nutrient density
when we think about brain health comes
down to b vitamins magnesium iron
we did a research study a really small
study that i did with dr laura lachance
who's also a psychiatrist where we just
said if we look at all the literature
what are the 12 nutrients that are most
important for brain health and
specifically depression that's the most
debilitating disease like
does something stand out and there are
12 nutrients that had really as we went
through like levels of evidence
significant data of both epidemiological
studies but also clinical trials we took
those 12 nutrients and i think this is
the most important thing people miss we
turn them into food we ask what foods
have the most of these nutrients and you
mentioned bivalve so
usually with these scales like the andy
the aggregate nutrient density index
it's all plants because plants always
have fewer calories and i didn't like
that because 98 of people eat meat or
seafood and i was curious so we listed
all the plants and what you'd expect
lots of leafy greens and rainbows but in
the animals three of the top five are bi
valves muscles clams and oysters and
when we were talking about that scale
these are things that contain the 12
the key nutrients
they
contain the most they're the foods with
the most of these 12 nutrients so i know
that number one on the plants is
watercress which is really uh you know
kind of leads for leafy greens but so
are all lettuces kale uh collard scales
like number 12 or 15. red peppers pomelo
and so that's the way i get to these
foods is through nutrient density that
then leads us to food categories and so
the bivalves and seafood are a food
category because they're the most
concentrated and only source of
long-chained omega-3 fats the omega-3
fats we make them in our liver a little
bit when we eat plant omega-3 fats but
there's reasonable data especially when
you think like the pregnancy data like
women who eat more fish their babies
tend to have like higher verbal iqs um
and less behaviorally tested
yeah nine verbal iq points if you feed
pregnant women if you give them salmon
um
there have been some really i'd love to
do a hardcore data deep dive with you
because i'm really curious what you
think about the studies but
there's a variety of data that if you
feed
kids pregnant moms and individuals more
seafood you see lower rates of
depression and bipolar disorder actually
one of the first studies in nutritional
psychiatry looked around the world at
intakes of seafood and found that
cultures that eat more seafood have
lower rates of bipolar illness rule
number nine identify the triggers with
dr rangan chatterjee i think
in my first book how to make disease
disappear i spoke about what i consider
to be the four
sort of pillars of health as it were the
four things i think have the most
impacts on our health but also we've got
a fair degree of control over
food movements which we've been talking
about for years but equally important
sleep and relaxation yeah and what was
quite clear to me is that
people were feeding back to me that the
pillar they were struggling with the
most or many of them were was the whole
relaxed pillar this whole piece about
stress people were sort of thinking
about their food and their movement but
they really struggled with stress and i
thought
you know what food gets a lot of air
time movement gets a lot of air time i
don't think stress is getting the air
time that it deserves and that's why i
thought well i'm going to write a book
on stress to really elevate it in in
terms of our consciousness in terms of
what we're thinking about and you
mentioned in the introduction the world
health organization right now if you go
on their website we'll say that stress
is
the health epidemic of the 21st century
now that's an alarming statement the
health epidemic wow yeah i mean that's
incredible and then i might fight a
little bit without i think food per food
problem is big one
right up there it's right up there well
i think stress and food is linked
actually because actually our diet
you probably know this but our diet if
it's bad causes physiologic stress so
when you eat sugar and crap it actually
raises your cortisol and stress hormones
100 even if you're not mentally stressed
it makes you physically stressed well a
lot of these things actually as you know
mark work both ways so yeah the poor
poor dietary choices um can send
stress signals up to your brain good
food choices can send calm signals up to
your brain or this is all to do with the
gut brain axis which you know you've
written about before i've written about
in this book
um but also i would say it works both
ways so if you are chronically stressed
yeah it's quite hard to make those good
healthy food choices and i you know
let's take january in in the uk and the
us
every january people are trying to get
healthy i'm going to reduce my sugar
intake this year i'm going to cut out
alcohol this year
but here's the problem i've seen is that
people can use willpower for a week for
two weeks maybe three weeks
but if the sugar or the alcohol was
being used to help them soothe the
stresses in their life
they're never gonna maintain it long
term so i actually i agree food is a big
problem but i found with some patients
addressing their stress levels means
they feel less of a need
to you know
to binge on sugar because they're not
feeling a stress if you're happy you
know you're not going to eat that bag of
chips or cookies yeah because a lot of a
lot of our food choices are dictated by
our emotions and you know if we're
feeling down if we're feeling stressed
we feel we've got too much on actually
that sugary chocolate bar or that bag of
chips actually helps us feel good in
that moment so short-term benefit but
long-term harm i tell a story in
in my book about
this chap who i saw
um he was
a
you know busy business guy in his early
50s and
what was really interesting about him is
that
we start to measure something called
heart rate variability on him so higher
variability yeah what is that it's you
know basically
it's a measure of how what what is the
beat to beat variation between our
heartbeats now people will think it
should be like a metronome you know tick
tock tick tock 70 70 70 yeah but that's
actually incorrect what we're looking
for is a high degree of variability
complexity yeah complexity and it shows
that we're constantly adapting and able
to adapt to this changing environment
around us
and what was interesting because the
worst
heart rhythm is
got no variability it's a flat line yeah
so a low heart rate variability is
actually indicative that we've got high
stress levels in our body
and this chap actually on a
wednesday evening he would find that he
was drinking a lot of alcohol he wasn't
sleeping well he was having a lot of
caffeine on thursday
more alcohol on the thursday he was
basically he came in he was really
really stressed uh it was impacting his
relationships impacting his sleep etc
etc the very common story but as we
start to look at his life and actually
use hiv heart rate variability readings
we could see that everything changed for
him on a wednesday so what happened on a
wednesday
lunchtime he had a team meeting right he
found that incredibly stressful they had
to present to his team it was quite a
high pressure meeting and that stress
would last throughout the day so what
would happen is on a wednesday
late afternoon when he would leave work
he had to compensate with that stress
how would he do that alcohol alcohol so
he'd open a bottle of wine he'd have a
glass that glass one glass would turn
into two two two would turn into three
and by the end of the evening he'd had
the whole bottle of wine so what happens
then he doesn't sleep well on the
wednesday nights so thursday morning
he's feeling groggy he needs lots of
coffee lots of sugar to get him through
coffee in the afternoon as well which
again impacts his ability to sleep on
thursday nights he's not feeling good
and that cycle continues where he's
having a bottle of wine on thursday two
bottles of wine on the friday
and etc etc but what did we do we
identified his trigger point was a
wednesday lunchtime
so
i could show him that on the data he
could see it very clearly so we we we
discussed about certain things he might
be able to do on a wednesday evening
instead of alcohol now there was a
massage
well it was a yoga class very near his
office so before he went home he went to
the yoga class so what happens then he
goes to that yoga class that helps him
de-stress when he gets home he no longer
feels the need to drink a bottle of wine
yeah so he might have a glass but it's
one glass and it stops there he sleeps
well
thursday he feels fresh he doesn't get
as stressed at work he doesn't have as
much coffee
and before you know it all we had to do
was give him a yoga class on a wednesday
afternoon and suddenly that changed this
whole week and and people who were
listening to this i'd really ask them to
reflect on their own life and think
actually is there a trigger point in my
week where things start to go downhill
yeah because if you can identify that
and change your behavior it is
incredible what you can achieve and rule
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips is frame your story
with sam harris mindfulness is a way of
kind of dropping a little bit lower and
realizing so in this case
if you're feeling anxiety
there's actually a place from which you
can just feel it right and
and be
actually indifferent to it or anything
else you could be feeling i mean just
just notice that there's even an
unpleasant sensation
i mean first you can notice that anxiety
isn't even that unpleasant i mean it's
so close to excitement in its actual
physiology that really the difference
between excitement and anxiety is more
or less just the the framing it's just
the story you're telling yourself you
know if you felt these these
tingles
and this you know slightly adrenalized
response
right before you know you're about to go
on a roller coaster that's part of why
you're going on the roller coaster you
like that experience right but the fact
that you feel that way when you're about
to have an interview or you're about to
you know walk out on stage that's
intolerable right so just dropping back
and realizing the the power of the
framing is again this is a skill that is
a fairly esoteric one but now you know
many people are learning it you know the
secrets out
um
and it has immense utility because then
you can realize that the
the half-life of negative emotions is
incredibly short i mean one you could
you can actually be
psychologically free even in their
presence right your your freedom and
your well-being isn't even predicated on
getting rid of the physiology right like
it can still be there but
if you're not
continually thinking about all the
reasons why you should be anxious
the physiology dissipates very very
quickly and that's true for anger it's
true for anything that is
classically negative
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week the science says that when you just
watch a video you get motivated to get
inspired you have a 35 chance of
following through on your goals 35
that's not enough that's not enough just
to get motivated believe nation we're
here you're here today matters you're an
action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
it goes back to the teachings of
epictetus the greek
stoic philosopher who said
roughly 2 000 years ago that people are
disturbed not by things not by events
not by what happens to us but by our
views of them
and that idea is so simple and basic
that most people
can't grasp what it means we'll we'll
come back to that in in a minute
now the the second idea is that when
you're depressed and anxious again it's
not the events of your life that are
upsetting you it's it's the messages
you're giving yourself the way you're
interpreting events
and when you're depressed you're giving
yourself messages like i'm not as good
as i should be and there's a lot of
people listening right now who
are thinking that
and uh
or if you're shy you may be thinking you
know why am i so shy i'm really screwed
up uh
there must be something wrong with me
depressed people often feel discouraged
or hopeless and then you're telling
yourself
things will never change
this is my true self i really am a loser
i'll be this way
forever
and
now and the really uh amazing thing that
that's been kind of known what i just
said
more or less for 2000 years but what's
really kind of new and awesome
is that the thoughts that trigger
depression and anxiety are not valid
thoughts depression and anxiety is the
world's
oldest con
and you're fooling yourself but you
don't you don't realize it
and then
the final
message from cognitive behavioral
therapy is the very moment you change
the way you think in other words the
moment you can you suddenly see that
those distorted thoughts aren't true and
you stop believing them in that instant
uh you can change postpartum depression
obviously hormonal
well yeah
how is that just her thoughts yeah well
um
it's not only her thoughts but her
motivation
to to to be depressed but what she was
telling herself is is
i'm a failure as a mother she was having
trouble with breastfeeding
and i and i shouldn't have mixed
feelings about having a baby because she
wasn't even sure
she she wanted to have have a baby and
then she was telling herself i have the
wrong emotions i should be better at
breastfeeding i'm failing as a mother
she was beating up on herself and it's
those thoughts not some
presumed hormonal imbalance that's
causing her depression what is she
telling herself well she's telling
herself it's my fault that that the baby
isn't nursing
i i'm a failure as a mother
and also
i shouldn't have mixed feelings about
having a child mothers are supposed to
just love that their children
and uh
and those thoughts have all of the
classic cognitive distortions for
example uh should statements i i i
shouldn't have mixed mixed feelings
also
self-blame
it it's my fault that the baby is is
having trouble
nursing
that that type of thing and
she had about eight thoughts and they
all had multiple distortions you know
all or nothing thinking looking at
things in black or white
uh categories emotional reasoning is
huge
a lot of people are listening right now
feel depressed
and hopeless so that they feel like
losers so they say i must be a loser i
feel like a loser i must be hopeless i i
feel hopeless
she's also involved in mind reading
uh thinking oh other mothers don't have
mixed feelings other mothers are you
know these ideal
ideal mothers
and and so that's the first step is to
recognize that what you're telling
yourself
is not true
it's it's distorted and the second thing
is to realize that it's it's kind of
mean-spirited what what you're doing to
yourself it turns out that one of the
best stress relievers on the planet is
something that most of us don't ever do
and that is seek out time with friends
when we feel totally stressed out when
you're doing twice as much work as you
normally do or you're feeling twice as
much stress as you normally feel
studies at harvard show that what you
need is you need to see your friends
twice as much
now sean anker is a really famous
researcher and best-selling author at
harvard and he studied this phenomenon
he looked at at people that were
stressed at schools and in call centers
and in the military and in banks and in
almost every single industry what he
discovered is that the most successful
people the people that were the best at
selling the people that they were the
most resilient the people that had the
best ability to deal with stress when
times got tough were the ones that saw
their friends the most it was the people
with the tightest social connections
that had the ability to weather the
storms that life throw at us i want you
to write down three people
three people that when you hang out with
them you feel energized that when you
have plans with them you're excited
about seeing them
when this video ends reach out to them
that's right pick up the phone send them
a text i want you to invite them to do
something go out to lunch go for a walk
in the woods get a cup of coffee go out
to dinner even if you're not stressed
out i guarantee you at least one of the
three people that you're gonna reach out
to needs you as i said seventy percent
of the time people live in stress and
living in stress is living in survival
now
all organisms in nature can tolerate
short-term stress you know a deer gets
chased
by a pack of coyotes when it outruns the
coyotes it goes back to grazing and the
event is over and the definition of
stress is when your brain and body are
knocked out of balance out of
homeostasis
the stress response is what the body
innately does to return itself back to
order so you're driving down the road
someone cuts you off you jam on the
brakes you may you give them the finger
and then you settle back down and the
event is over and boom now everything's
back back to normal
but what if it's not a predator that's
waiting for you
outside the cave but what if it's your
co-worker
sitting right next to you and all day
long you're turning on those chemicals
because they're pushing all your
emotional buttons
when you turn on the stress response
and you can't turn it off
now you're headed for disease because no
organism in nature can live in emergency
mode for that extended period of time
it's a scientific fact that the hormones
of stress down regulate genes and create
disease long-term effects
human beings because of the size of the
neocortex we can turn on the stress
response just by thought alone we can
think about our problems and turn on
those chemicals
that means then
our thoughts
could make us sick
so if it's possible that our thoughts
could make us sick is it possible then
our thoughts can make us well
the answer is absolutely yes
so then what are the emotions that are
connected to survival let's name them
anger aggression hostility
hatred competition fear anxiety worry
pain suffering guilt shame unworthiness
envy jealousy those are all
created by the hormones of stress and
and psychology calls them normal human
states of consciousness i call those
altered states of consciousness
so then we tend to remember those
traumatic events more because in
survival you better be ready if it
happens again that's and and the
survival gene is switched on you could
have 10 really great things that happen
to you in your day
and you just have one bad thing that
happens and you cannot take your
attention off that bad that that unhappy
thing because the survival gene is
switched on many years ago after the dna
helix was discovered by watson crick
they said the blueprints of life you
know all diseases are created from genes
it turns out less than five percent more
like one percent of people on the planet
are born with a genetic condition like
type 1 diabetes or tay sachs disease or
sickle cell anemia the other 95 to 99
percent are created by lifestyle and by
choices you can take two identical twins
exact same genome one dies at 51. the
other one dies at 85.
same gene different environment so
all of a sudden they said we lied
that was wrong it's not genes that
create disease it's the environment that
signals the gene that creates disease
well okay
but that's not the whole truth too
because you could have two people
working side by side in the same factory
one gets cancer after being exposed to a
carcinogenic for 25 years both working
for 25 years the other one has no cancer
at all
so there must be some internal order
that would cause one person to not get
it while another one does
so
is it possible then
if the environment signals the gene and
it does and the end product of an
experience in the environment is called
an emotion can you signal the gene ahead
of the environment by embracing an
elevated emotion
we've done the research on this we
measured
7500 different gene expressions in a
group of people
that came to an advanced event for four
days
and we had them doing a seated
meditation a walking meditation a laying
down meditation a standing meditation
and at the end of four days just four
days
the common eight genes that were up
regulated two genes to suppress cancer
cells and tumor growth
two genes for neurogenesis the growth of
new neurons in response to novel
experiences and learning the gene that
signals stem cells to go to damaged
areas and repair them the gene for
oxidative stress
was upregulated we started seeing all
these genes that are very very healthy
to cause the body to flourish imagine if
people were doing that for three months
we also measured telomeres the little
shoe strings on the end of dna that tell
us our biological age we asked people
to do the work meditation five out of
seven days for 60 days
measure their telomeres that determine
their biological age 60 days later
74 of the people lengthen their
telomeres 40
significant change 20
a very remarkable change that means that
they got a little bit of their life back
if it lengthened by ten percent they got
ten percent of their life back i created
a method
the components are breathing
mindset
and cold
exposure gradual non-forced cold
exposure
and that's to optimize the mind body
connection
wim has figured out ways namely through
breath work and through exposure to cold
to take conscious control over aspects
of his physiology
that for most people they simply can't
tune into and control
[Music]
be called
my warm friend it brings about a whole
lot of more energy and that
together with breathing
makes you so powerful
but then you lose your
wife and
at all
rumbles down
four children out with my wife
and i was to be with her forever
she was the love of my life
she died
she suicided
it's a it's a black hole within yourself
it breaks your heart and you don't know
why but the train of her daily life is
going on and you gotta catch up
otherwise you lose it
so i had to be there for my children and
yes
we created a new nest
my children made me survive in that
time but
nature healed my words
the cold gave me a direct understanding
of deeper breathing
and how to heal a broken heart then i
went and did all kinds of remarkable
challenges apparently they found it very
remarkable and great and spectacular so
it came in contact with television one
after the other they challenged me more
more more more more they go swim 50
meters under the ice go swim 100 meters
under the ice climb mount everest in
shorts that led up
that the scientists
became curious
hey what this man is doing is not
possible physiologically
the science of what wim hof method does
is one of the primary interests of my
lab now because it is so powerful and
it's been shown to be powerful in the
immune system we believe it will also
hold some real potential for treatment
of neurological diseases
and this breathing technique brings you
right into the deepest part of
physiology anybody can do it so you
become the alchemist
of your own chemistry when i was growing
up i had met my guru when i was about 21
and i was going to join
his monastic order which was in hawaii
i was at that time living in western
australia and studying in university
and i remember in my last year of
engineering i
was feeling extremely stressed i had a
thesis which i'd been working on for a
year and a half that i needed to
complete
in the next month
i
had about seven or eight examinations
that i had to pass in order to graduate
as an engineer
i was the president of the youth group
uh of our temple over that local temple
over there and we were organizing a lot
of different events and i was also
dancing
as part of a dance company that i was
involved in and they were also putting
up a big show so we were rehearsing
almost every night and i remember
emailing my guru saying
gurudeva i'm really stressed i have all
these things going on
and i'm stressed
he emailed me back and i don't remember
the exact words that he he used but he
emailed me back and said
the reason you're stressed is because
you don't keep your awareness on one
thing at a time and i'll be absolutely
honest with you
ever since that day i've never felt
stressed anymore and uh i know it's a
very bold proclamation to make but it's
true
because
i clearly understood what he said to me
at that point whenever i was dancing
i was thinking about my thesis and when
i was working on my thesis i was
thinking about the exams i had to do
when i was thinking working on my exams
when i was studying for my exams i was
thinking about the youth group
and
wherever i was i was thinking about
something else anxiety comes because we
allow awareness to drift away from the
present moment and go into the future or
into the past in an uncontrolled way so
the past and the future are not bad
things as long as we indulge in them or
we enter them
with the aim to learn from them
but we don't we just allow awareness to
travel into the past into the future all
the time it creates anxiety and we do
that because we're afraid
anxiety comes out of a sense of fear
where we allow awareness to go into the
future we create a situation that hasn't
happened
we bring it back into the present and
start living it as it has already
happened
you keep repeating the process over and
over and over again
you build anxiety i'm going to get sick
i'm going to get sick
you think in the future what if i get
sick
then what happens oh my god i'm gonna
get sick and you bring back the present
and you start living that five minutes
later you let your awareness go into the
future you think to yourself i'm not
gonna get better i'm gonna get sick
and then you bring awareness back into
the present again and you start worrying
about it you keep repeating this process
over and over again and you build
anxiety
so
the way to get overcome stress and
anxiety is to really control where your
awareness goes every time the awareness
goes into the future or into the past in
an uncontrolled way bring it back to the
present again and just do this exercise
be mindful of this throughout the entire
day don't let your awareness go into the
past or into the future in an
uncontrolled way get consumed by the
positive energy
focus not on your bad habits
get consumed not by the negative energy
of your bad habits sometimes we just get
so consumed by it that all that's
playing on our mind is that
no
that's meant to be dealt with
focus
on the good things that are happening in
your life
and to focus on the good things and be
grateful doesn't happen automatically
it's not our default setting our default
setting is to go towards the negative
our default setting is it to focus on
the negative
we have to customize our lives
by being consciously aware
we have to become more mindful and
conscious of the wonderful
gifts the wonderful opportunities the
wonderful blessings that we've been
showered with
and with that
positive energy
with that positive emotion of gratitude
feel
tremendously empowered
to deal with our bad habits to deal with
our challenges
and therefore
do not be hateful about what you're
going through in life
be grateful
for all those wonderful gifts that
you've been given in your life
[Music]
if you want to learn how to beat anxiety
with mel robbins check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there i want you to actually make a
more concerted effort to re-engage
every one of us has an internal fuel
tank
that is either empty